hi i'm kyle gass and i'm jack black we
are tenacious d and we're going
undercover on the internet because this
is actually me tenacious being reddit
first question what is the most
tenacious d song the d has to offer you
know like what song comes to mind when
you hear tenacious d well i think this
is easy it's so easy obviously the first
song we ever wrote tribute it
encapsulates what we're all about
yeah there's a there's a little bit of
Zeppelin mm-hmm there's a little bit of
devil went down to georgia yeah yeah is
that old parable robert johnson where
you go down and you meet the devil and
get challenged in battle it really set
us on our course and you know it's about
being the greatest band in the world in
our own minds and and therefore opening
the keys to the universe if you believe
in yourself and your dreams reach for
the stars but keep your feet on the
ground Yahoo Answers it's actually me
it's actually we what does Tenacious D
mean I'm a fan of the band and I was
wondering what does the name of the band
mean and is there any background meaning
well it was taken from a sporting term
initially tenacious defense but over the
years and decades it's taken on so many
meanings tenacious dormitory tenacious
dumbass tenacious domicile it's a dumb
name for a band
but we're stuck with it because are you
gonna change the band now that'd be like
changing your name from the police to
like sting it doesn't work next weeks
what's the cool gamertag for Xbox that
has to do with Tenacious D and the pike
of destiny Master exploder in extra
master exploder is probably taken so I
go master exploder 5000 or Master
exploder six six six many sixes is he
made until it's not taken submit flora
seriously it's me what is the best way
for me to acquire backstage tickets to a
Tenacious D concert well in the old days
of course you'd have to give us a a
compliment but no there's no backstage
tickets very strict no one backstage
rules we need to focus and concentrate
after show passes they're sometimes
available to a friends and family that's
a that's a hot potato I have nothing to
do with any of that no neither do I
posted who are the musicians who
recorded the Tenacious D album the Pick
of Destiny well that's not off to ask
well aside from me and Kyle obviously we
play our own instruments but we had an
all-star cast
we had meatloaf singing a song we had
Ronnie James Dio we had Dave Grohl on
drums also playing Satan you know we had
Sasquatch which is not an easy gift just
let you know John [ __ ] esky on electric
guitar jump Spiker on bass and I know
that's it yeah might had that dude from
fish playing a couple keys
sorry GQ Kyle's new to this sort of
thing tribute by June HST is a tribute
to what solo said me and my friend are
arguing over if this song is dedicated
to one by Metallica or stairway to
heaven by Led Zeppelin look they're
wrong both of them are wrong I mean we
had influence obviously there's
influence from the Zeppelin because we
use some of the chords not enough to sue
us and also there's influence of
Metallica one because we were listening
to that at the time of the recording of
the original version of the song but
neither of them are what we're
referencing when we sing about this is a
tribute we can't remember what the
original song what that's the whole
point
we can't remember what that song was
that we beat the devil with we didn't
beat him with a cover we came up with a
new song we wrote a song on this rock
improvisational to beat the devil and it
was the greatest song in that moment we
can't remember it that's the point it's
on my right it's actually me in the
tenacious d song kielbasa the lyrics
include the line Dianetics jr. much
better than Krishna what is Dianetics
jr.
why is it better than Krishnan well
Dianetics jr. is an offshoot of
Scientology that focused more on the
Dianetics book and it's a it's a
combination of Dianetics and dinosaur
jr. which is one of the greatest 1990s
alt rock bands when you put those two
together it's like a - Moroccan religion
it's better than Krishna which is also
very high on the list of greatest
airport dancing bands blast that what is
the origin of the idiom Faith Movement
there was a guitar tech guy at Guitar
Center is just like a STONER frog north
and he was like oh yeah you guys got a
good because I saw yes back in 79 face
melter and I took it I stole it and I
use I ran with that straight to the back
always have your eyes and ears open for
gold and fortunate nuggets of wisdom
Twitter
[Music]
why did tenacious d make a heavy metal
band with acoustic guitars
well Kyle taught me the ways it's
similar to the way that a kung-fu master
teaches a disciple on the acoustic
guitar because it is the purest form of
guitaring we're deadly more powerful
more hardrock than any electric guitar
get Italy I don't know why I bet have
put so much smarmy sauce on it's true at
Jack Black
goosebumps - dude I can't wait also
another possible Canisius D movie is it
true goosebumps - is happening as far as
I know I'm not part of the marketing I
don't know when the poster or in the
movie at all and also another possible
Tenacious D movie it is true oh yeah
it's an animated masterpiece that we did
everything on we wrote it directed it we
wrote we did the cartoons we did the
music we did all the voices and so in a
way this is more our baby than anything
we've ever done teens leaving pick up
Dustin it's actually pure this is
actually if I can pure Madigan D
manly and enter Wikipedia Jack Black and
Kyle Gass so far perfect true initially
met in Los Angeles true in 85 wait a
second wait a second I was a senior in
high school when I first met you you
don't remember because you were in love
with a woman at the time and you were
singing to her but I was there in the
room with you and I believe that was
1986
close close 1986 black admits the duo
did not see eye to eye do to animosity
between the two as gas was the main
musician for the actors gang and felt
threatened by black I think that's all
true the actors gang travelled to
Edinburgh Scotland for the Edinburgh
Fringe Festival in 1989 through the two
became friends during the trip and
eventually became best friends with
black regularly visiting gases Cochrane
half a new studio apartment in the deal
that gas would teach black to play
guitar in return for food mainly from
fast food chain jack-in-the-box I gotta
say every word of that whole thing is
true we called it jack in the crack back
in the day and our go-to was the the two
tacos for a dollar yeah I mean we worked
one dollar for two delicious for us we
were on a budget thing but if we really
wanted to splurge we'd go with the
monster tacos that included a little
extra lettuce and South but the jury was
up if they were actually better dude I
don't think we should eat those
artery-clogging more those days are gone
we're no longer young bucks
chowing down IMDB it says here that I
was born July 14th Bastille Day and 1960
in Walnut Creek California USA well
that's obviously incorrect I think it
was 70 there's nothing to be ashamed of
there she what your nor ashamed of being
born in 1960 it's like one of the best
years to be born we're both children of
the 60s after all cage born in 1960 me
born in 69 [ __ ] nothing wrong
with that birthday I'm Kyle Richard
gasps that's correct
nicknames Lada nicknames cage kg rage
clip Calhoun
but none of those are what Jack calls me
I call I call you a combo ridge gauge
which worked
Raj Kosh spelled with Jade's my height
is 5 9 1.75 meters that you say your
height
because I think it's height okay my IMDB
trademarks starts speaking in a slow
quiet tempo and begins to sing in a
faster louder K - that's not me I don't
do that I just get right now and it
didn't feel right
often plays slackers or sloppy infinite
laughs they couldn't even hear because
you were laughing so hard I know what
the [ __ ] that means sloppy like child
boy men not just I guess it's true it's
true expressive eyes eyebrows oh that's
[ __ ] absolutely true stocky frame duh
batting a thousand on IMDB [ __ ]
[ __ ]
YouTube's really rich one ski Oh
twister that's cool is that Val Kilmer
in the background at the end of the road
evideo but the ad is Val Kilmer a great
friend to the D threw down some tasty
ass cameos and more for the day over the
years my favorite to be the best to be
the best dude he really threw down some
sausage oh you're off the classic tasty
morsels for us and we love him deeply
well that was great I'm glad that we had
a chance to clear up someone Winston we
really answered a lot of great questions
with great great answers yeah thanks for
those great questions anyway that's me
and kg tenacious d over and out slam
that [ __ ] shut cage
[Music]